هنا ناتي الى ما بعرف شو بنسميها يعني
التعليم او لما يقول له علم لي اياه علمني
شو يعني
علم لي نظام المهدي سجن تدمر كل مهجاء فيه
شيء اسمه شراقه نعم السقف مفتوح
سقف مفتوح مثلا لنفرض 3 امتار مترين متر
ونص بمتر حسب حجم المهجى هاي الشراقه طبعا
فيها حديد اسلاك شاي كمان حتى حتى اذا حدا
حس انه يوصل للسقف ما بحسن يطلع منا لانه
هي حديد
في على السطح حرس
على كل سطح كل ما جاء حرس مهمته يحرس
وبنفس الوقت يراقب المهجه تعليم المعطاه
للسجناء بالمهجه بعد الساعه سته او سبعه
ممنوع الحركه
سجان اللي فوق الحرس في رئيس مهجعه هو
معين من قبل السجن من السجناء يعني هو
سجين بس يعني مثلا بيختاروا واحد كان
سابقا عسكري كان مساعد انه
انت رئيس مجال ولا يستطيع ان يرفض ان يكون
رئيس
المهجع بيكون دائما محله جنب الباب
قد يكون له امتياز انه ممكن ياخذ مساحه
اكثر من غيره ننفض 10 سنتي او خمسه عشر
سانتي بالعرض
السجان بس اذا شاف واحد من السجناء بعد
الزمن المضروب او الموعد المحدد اتحرك
بقول له علم لي هات
فبالليل الوحده حسب نفسيه السجان وحسب
تركيبته وحسب حقده حسب
مزاجه احيانا ايوه
وطبعا بعد ساعتين بيجي سجان تاني كمان
بعلم كمان ناس اخرين وهكذا للصبح يعني بين
السته والسته 12 ساعه بيؤدي سته سجانين كل
واحد منهم ممكن يعلم في معظم ما بعلم يعني
المعلمين
لازم رئيس
هذول لازم كلياتهم يطلعوا ياكلوا دولاب كل
واحد دولاب دولاب دولاب دولاب يعني